bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic l'expansion de l'univers
l'univers est composé d'une multitude
d'objets --des astres qui évoluent dans
l'espace et dans le temps
ces objets ces astres se déplacent les
uns par rapport aux autres comme la
terre qui orbite autour du soleil ou
encore le soleil qui orbite dans la
périphérie de la voie lactée
ainsi si l'on regarde l'univers à des
échelles relativement petites de l'ordre
des planètes ou des étoiles
les corps qui composent l'univers semble
se déplacer de manière hétérogène
presque aléatoire
en effet certains objets vont se
rapprocher et d'autres vont s'éloigner
mais si l'on regarde maintenant
l'univers à une échelle bien plus grande
on remarque que le mouvement des
galaxies et des amas de galaxies n'est
plus aléatoire les galaxy semble tout ce
éloignées les unes des autres
c'est cet éloignement des structures
cosmiques à grande échelle que l'on
appelle l'expansion de l'univers
dans un premier temps on pourrait penser
que comme lorsque l'on regarde l univers
à petite échelle les galaxies et les
amas se déplace dans un espace fixe et
que c'est ce déplacement relatif dans
l'espace qui les éloignerait les unes
des autres
cependant ce n'est pas le cas en effet à
ces échelles c'est l'espace lui-même qui
s'étire entraînant avec lui les galaxies
pour mieux comprendre cette situation on
peut imaginer l'univers comme la surface
d'un ballon de baudruche surface sur
laquelle se trouveraient les galaxies et
tout ce qui compose l'univers
imaginons maintenant que l'on gonfle
progressivement ce ballon en prenant du
volume la surface du ballon va augmenter
et ainsi on aura l'impression que les
galaxies s'éloignent les unes des autres
mais tout en restant même endroit sur la
surface du ballon les galaxies ne
s'éloigne donc pas parce qu'elles se
déplacent à la surface mais parce que
c'est la surface elle même qui s'étire
cette expansion de l'univers est
également caractérisé par le fait
qu'elle n'ait pas de centre en effet on
pourrait d'abord pensé que si toutes les
galaxies s'éloignent en inversant le
mouvement pourrait trouver un point
central depuis lequel elle s'éloigne
tout
cependant en reprenant l'image du ballon
le ballon a bel et bien un centre dans
son volume depuis lequel il gonfle mais
ce centre se situe à l'intérieur du
ballon
ainsi la surface en elle-même n'a pas de
centre on peut par exemple comparer
cette situation à la surface de la terre
en effet la ville de paris n'est pas
plus au centre que la ville de londres
ou encore celle de new york
par conséquent ou que l'on se situe sur
la surface du ballon c'est à dire dans
l'univers on aura toujours l'impression
d'être au centre de l'expansion est
ainsi où que l'on se trouve dans
l'univers on verra les galaxies
s'éloignent et de nous ceux-ci s'observe
également avec leurs lumières
en effet où que l'on se trouve dans
l'univers si on regarde des galaxies
autour de nous on les verra légèrement
rouge
ce décalage spectral est due à
l'expansion de l'univers
en effet les galaxies émettent une
lumière
sous la forme d'une onde
électromagnétique qui va se propager
dans l'espace jusqu'à nos yeux mais avec
l'expansion
l'espace entre la galaxie à nous-mêmes
va s'étirer et un si long d'électro
magnétique va s'étirer avec l'espace
ceci va avoir pour effet d'allonger la
longueur d'onde de cette lumière et
ainsi de décaler la couleur vers le
rouge l'expansion nous indique ainsi que
l'univers n'est pas statique qu'il
évolue dans le temps et qui n'a pas
toujours été comme nous le connaissons
aujourd'hui
or si l'univers est aujourd'hui en
expansion
on peut supposer que si l'on remonte le
temps assez loin il y environ 14
milliards d'années
il a existé un instant où l'univers
était concentrée en un seul point
infiniment danse une singularité
gravitationnelle au moment du big bang
cette singularité se serait dilater très
rapidement puis l'expansion ray
progressivement ralenti on pourrait
alors imaginer que cette expansion
devrait actuellement être en train de
ralentir
en effet la gravité ne cesse d'attirer
tous les objets entre eux et donc de
rapprocher des galaxies entre elles
cependant toutes les observations au
contraire indique que l'expansion de
l'univers est en train de s'accélérer
ceci pourrait impliquer l'existence
d'une énergie encore inconnue très
importante qui seraient présentes
partout dans l'univers et qui pousserait
l'expansion à s'accélérer
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'énergie noire